[Music]
now on a mission what we're saying at
this bad was like $80 and I was like
you're crazy
so now I'm signing it for $10 why could
you okay thank you so much
mission number one complete mission
number two helps me to find a hat
because tomorrow we're gonna be doing a
really fun adventure row is a meeting up
here in Hawaii and we're going on a
really cool canoe hi kids a lot of stuff
going on but they said we need a hat
perhaps not unnecessary but like I want
to ask cover something I think this is
good this is cute for working to change
your by mas a are you here Oh coughing
that's not your of Amazo
you're watching did you have fun table
I think I'm just going to get one egg
[Music]
new men
I'll search for some water shoes oh I
found them
look these are it why is my family
I forgot shorts and yes what I did I
brought short hikes it
I was thinking yes for like now I'm
thinking moving you know I'm not sure
like I think now I get really difficult
it's a little big I think I can find
something cutter looks like a little
Sally looks so good
yep that's basically my motto and
they've also a supercool shark paintings
this place is so cool
Hanalei is my BAE you
[Music]
the last time that I was the former was
2010 with three when we came to Kauai
and it was kind of crazy going back and
watching the gold vlogs because I don't
remember any of it it was like it didn't
even happen we are at the Walmart
oh I spotted I spot next well except
telephoto this one you get I'm looking
at myself in that should I get adjourned
Pina backpack for the Disney Princesses
19 is said and I just got a confession
which one you like more John Cena
like a hundred to happen alright John
Cena John Cena is blogging in the first
place I can't remember anything
Mike you remember this Walmart I bought
a John Cena backpack
now I was living we actually don't even
need anything in here but it's raining
so we thought this would be a very fun
adventurous little trip cuse Walmart I
think one of the biggest differences
between now and then is my videos are
mostly in 4k any socks socks and visit
Boston scissors because a tag honestly
my sports bra you hit the jackpot affirm
mmm
beef looks good oh look at this cute
little Batman nighttime shirt so the guy
that we rented has a CD player and the
problem is it also has an aux cable and
I don't have a dongle or an aux cable so
I can't buy a CD album that started it
all okay really know which one are we
going to get wise greatest hit you see
any Martin garrix
I think Martin has an album out here
know some of that now so I checked
action to you hmm what if we do now
that's what I call music
there a look Martin garrix for beauty
Rexha great now that's what i call music
61 I think I remember now that's what i
call music 1 oh my god I've been having
so much in solder lately with the
original iPod but first this is one of
my first album meatloaf bat out of hell
now I do anything full but I won't
- Bruno Mars Kendrick Lamar I think this
is probably going to be our best bet 22
songs I'm pretty sons oh my god I love
this album so much this is like the best
one stream that I've ever found it's
basically like a little do you learn
stick and you just kind of like rub it
on it's so great but it goes really
really quick so you're going to be on
them or throw out I'd recommend getting
to music finally
none of the radio stations work
Ferguson bebe Rexha and Martin G
oh yeah it was re they found like this
place would be really good shape ice and
it's like a little trailer type thing
another super cute little warehouse it's
like like just everything just so cute
oh my goodness look at this little tiny
shirt
not eat bread anymore but I think I
might have to forget that not much do
you want a family
what do you want all these Asians okay
me too can we get a few girls Ethan oh
boy we're getting a grilled cheese in
the middle of nowhere this is great
nothing big kind of took like another
turn or just whatever because it's not
raining so we plan on going to a really
cool bike ride so that it was raining
and now we're going to end up going to
Waimea Canyon which I went there once
exam well
[Music]
this is a beautiful beautiful surprise I
can't believe it a girl cute little
nowhere on the way he knows we're going
on a little corn and a grilled cheese
like a little cranberry this is like a
decadent yeah it looks so good yeah
hoping you never what a coffee shave ice
before this is the first oh yeah yeah
yeah Arjun unique flavors make them
something that's going to be a little
more highbrow from the mill yes -
chilled corn syrup we don't focus on any
of God's moral maze like water gas syrup
ingredient in history so and then Oh be
my special oh that's so cool it is so
good Oh quite happiness
ooh this one is the professor the origin
of shave ice it came over from Japan to
the migrant workers and they leave their
course shaved down lock - favor sir
oh wow that's how she came to life
[Music]
Oh
and made it
Waimea Canyon so pretty with I wish that
you could see it if you realize I mean
you're seeing it with you realize now
but like through a camera
[Music]
something that factors inside the island
it takes about three and half hours to
get here because it's a long drive it's
also pretty much on top of a mountain
overlooking the canyon so we're heading
back now not sure if I would definitely
recommend driving all the way for like a
five second view but it is really pretty
but you don't have anything else to do
check it out or if you're actually close
to here then good luck
super
[Music]
perfect many hours later to Walmart
because the aux cable that I thought I
found straight I just found an aux cable
in the parking lot now I just need a
dongle totally totally normal is
actually this aux cable extender so it
wouldn't even work anyway so we're
getting that and also getting a little
GoPro clamp something to attach to a
kayak tomorrow in our back in Walmart I
mean to time one day the great way to
end today literally to Agassi sings
the first place
Walmart took everything except Tylenol
they're trying to keep me from feeling
in it that's pretty cool Wow
boot eating pizza pie stop holy moly
well I overall to just realize like the
last and that we're here sitting in the
same exact place they're putting on CD
but that was how many hours there was
not a lot really see a lot sick that's
it this is where I am vlog today so see
you guys later
oh yeah
riveting content just about me I'm poor
and I'm pretty like because this would
be last pair of air pods that they have
in the store this is just a few days ago